and thank goodness the winds calm down
for mother's day because i know a lot of
folks had plans
outdoors celebrating with mom it wasn't
too hot but it was warm we were
pushing close to 90 degrees yesterday at
least we got all those winds
calmed down for sunday temperatures are
nice out there we've got mostly 60s
couple of places downtown
the strip still around 70 degrees we've
had breezes at nellis
along the strip out in boulder city this
morning we're looking for a nice monday
very much like what we had temperature
wise over the weekend with 89 degrees
that's where we were saturday
sunday we'll be there today we'll keep
80s just barely
for the next couple of days before those
hot 90s come back
record today 102. sunrise was 5 38 and 7
36
is the sunset so we're under what we
call a zonal flow
not quite that bridge that ridge
building in yet of high pressure but it
will
as the week goes on there's a little
snow left in denver this morning big
thunderstorms across the gulf coast
with some flooding rains there and we
can't get a drop
89 is what we're looking for with lots
of good sunshine some northerly breezes
for the morning then things will be
pretty calm for the afternoon
88 tomorrow works into some warmer 90s
midweek and then we're
jumping up even close to the century
mark again for thursday friday
yeah it's going to be hot but winds
again over the weekend will help break
down that heat
to the 80s again by sunday monday so a
little more comfortable there
our